FE RESITTEF HE STILL
JOTHT DG HIM IF HE'D
NOT.
TERVIEW.
IT ENDED WITH MUSKTHE EMPLOYEE'S
BIE EMPLOYEEFIRMING HE
MO BEEN .BLIC I
.M
DUFFEY IS IN READ THFOR THE
NG.ARLY, WHEND HIM PERHAPUNFAIRA
TO S THEOR MANLLING OUT ANN LET.
I THINK IS VERWHAVE
HIS EMUSED ABOUT WERBEEN LAID OO
EET- SEE CERISTIC MUSKANIS?R OF
E THE UNDERLYINGTO RF.SKPL I THI
YEEMPLOYEES, JUSIO UNCERTAINTY
TWORKING FOR ANY.
T WN THREE
T THEIR INITIAL
WAS T
T THNY
AGO?KE A LISTEN.
D T TODI
AN PERSPECTIVE THAT
IN>> JUSTINT MORE
ERTE, WAS AN
TH MUSK'S TWIT
HS.EOR, THE ELON
, HE WASE
T WAS HAPPENING,
WASN HNG.
MY CHILD.YING TO PREECE, TOHOI E
>> WT HEARINGROTWTECULETHROUGH?
>>S, A LAYOFFS.
TIEDAID
TWITTES LEADERSHIP ATH WAS VAGUE
THLLOWING SK
HAVE NOTNGRRY ABOUYOFFS., GN
YOSO, YOU KNOW, I THOUGH W
ANYTHG TO WORRY
T.
ICANT CONTRIR.THE HAVE BN >> LAT
T 1500 FORMER TWITTER
EMPLOYEE'SAKING LEGAL ANY.
INCLTHE Y VECUERSEPAAG EMPLOYEEU
THEY WOULD GET.
TO KEEP PEOPERE
E PROM, THEMTHEM IN ITY
QUESTIONLL
AND THESOMO THE L
NG IT' POST SOME O
LAYOFFS WEFUL AND PUSHGATATION F
LONG WEEK.LIER ONE NIGHT IN
THAT WEEK, LIK H STA
N THIS
THING.
SO, THAT NIGHT, E D
HESOR LATER,
G,EYLAOP WEIRD
I CAN'T LO.
LLY WEONLONDON
WHIPLASH Y HAVE MASSIVE
OWN EARLTHIS WF,IG
A FIREFIGHNG. GO
>> MOLLYH FIRST CHILD IN JUA
D S THMAEX WAS ALSO ICH
FER. I
. WHAT
EARING T, D,
YOKNACQUISITION, AND THA
THED OUTCHTHAT'S NOW
REAL